unser bedürfnis nach nahrung brachte ein
fragiles ökosystem hervor dass seine
grenzen erreicht hat
aufgrund des bevölkerungswachstums
werden wir bis 2050 70 prozent mehr
nahrung produzieren müssen entscheiden
wie können wir in zeiten des
klimawandels mit weniger dünger auf
derselben fläche genug nahrung für eine
stetig wachsende weltbevölkerung
roboter arbeiten in der landwirtschaft
ktm sie sich nicht nur um das komplette
welt sondern um jede heizung platz in
der natur das heißt bietet lösungen wenn
ich nur einen weg finden sie sinnvoll
anzuwenden
jeder von uns kann eine bessere zukunft
schafft besser für seine mitmenschen
sich selbst und den plan an der tria
anlass muss nicht im widerspruch stehen